hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear show and this
is the last installment of giallo july
but don't be upset if you really like
these giallo movie reviews then you know
i'm gonna always be doing glo movie
reviews because i really like them you
know i might do another month where it's
nothing but yellow movies but there will
still be glo movie reviews sprinkled
throughout the other ones in the other
months as well so don't worry they're
not going away
so the one i'm talking about today this
one's a little bit of an odd one
now uh we've talked about
sergio martino before probably one of
the best regarded directors of giallo
movies he did other ones as well like a
lot of italian directors as well they
worked in other genres but he's probably
best known uh you know easily best known
in the us for all of his uh jello films
the ones that he did in the 1970s i
think he did some in the 1980s too but
they aren't as well regarded uh most of
the ones that he did in the 1970s i've
already talked about like in one format
or another like video or i wrote about
them or something like that he did um
strange advice of mrs ward the case of
the scorpion's tale uh your vice is a
locker room and only i have the key all
the colors of the dark with that which i
think i just talked about a couple weeks
ago and torso which i think i also
reviewed a little while back so like i
said i've either written reviews or done
video reviews of pretty much all of
those maybe actually maybe all of those
now that i'm thinking about it
however i will say that the one in his
70s cycle that i never seen and never
got around to
was his 1975 film the suspicious death
of a miner and this was the last giallo
he did like i said during his 70s cycle
you know he did do some in the 80s but
they weren't as well received
this one doesn't get brought up all that
much when discussing his work probably
because it's a little bit unconventional
for the
giallo genre i feel like it is
considered a giallo and it does actually
have a lot of the tropes of giallo
movies but it's also crossbred with
another uh italian crime genre which i'm
sure i'm pronouncing this wrong but it's
probably it's called uh pulitzio teshi
or teki i'm not really tesky i'm not
really sure how you pronounce that but
uh basically that is kind of like a jl
movie but it focuses more on
the police procedural aspect and there's
usually an aspect too of you know the
kind of rogue cop the cop that doesn't
play by the rules your dirty hairy kind
of beverly hills cop lethal weapon type
of thing uh it usually has a character
like that like one cop who doesn't play
by the rules so this one is kind of like
more focused on that than on maybe some
more giallo stuff like you know kind of
ultra violent fetishized murders of
women by like a masked and gloved killer
now suspicious death which i think was
also released in some territories under
the name uh too young to die
also has and i thought this was very
very weird but it also has like some
light-hearted comedy bits
which uh some of it's kind of shading
over into slapstick at least in the
first half of the movie uh tonally this
is a bit strange considering that the
bulk of the plot centers around an
underage human trafficking ring but you
know okay that's what you want to do so
our main protagonist is an undercover
detective named paolo jeremy now he's
actually played by claudio casanelli who
sadly died in 1985 like he was only 46
years old in a helicopter crash on the
set of another sergio martino movie
which was actually like a science
fiction film which was called a vendetta
del futuro or hands of steel i think
that's what it was called in the u.s
i've actually never seen that but he
died on the set of that unfortunately
like i said he was actually quite young
and he had a family as well so yeah very
sad but he's in this movie too so at the
beginning of the movie jeremy who we
don't actually find out is a cop until
later on it's like i feel like that's
not a spoiler because i think it says in
the synopsis of the movie that it's like
an undercover cop but they actually
don't tell you that he's an undercover
cop until like later on in the movie
now so at the very beginning he's kind
of hitting on this young woman who has
kind of like little orphan annie hair
she's sitting alone at this outdoor cafe
garden party i'm not really sure what
the situation is it's broad daylight
it's not nighttime or anything but
there's like tables and people are
sitting around drinking cappuccinos or
whatever but then there's like a whole
bunch of people dancing it almost looked
like a wedding i thought it was like a
wedding like at the beginning of the
godfather but i guess it's not
so and the music too is kind of like
also reminded me of like the godfather
because it's like super super italian
which i thought was like you know when
you stereotypically like think of like
old italian music that's what you think
of so that's what they're dancing to now
the woman uh that he's hitting on the
orphanage woman
she kind of seems initially like she's
pretty immune to uh jeremy's sort of
slick come on you know coming up being
like hey you're alone i'm alone you know
there's that whole thing so uh yeah but
it does appear that she's in some kind
of danger as though there's like a
couple of these sinister looking dudes
like in really dark sunglasses creeping
around kind of like the periphery of the
crowd they're clearly looking for her
and she's just kind of like oh [ __ ] they
found me you know what i mean
so
she basically like takes advantage of
jeremy being there she's like okay yeah
come dance with me and like she kind of
like pushes herself up and like brings
him in for a kiss like trying to hide
her face and [ __ ] like that uh but it
doesn't really work for all that long
the goons actually end up spotting her
and she takes off she basically buy and
then like she takes off running and then
this ends up like breaking the lens on
jeremy's glasses
which is gonna be like a repeating gag
like thrust throughout the rest of the
movie like he's always getting involved
in these scrapes and like one lens on
his glasses will break and he'll be like
[ __ ] and then like he has to go get
another pair and like yeah it's like
like i said it's a running gag so this
young woman who we later find out is
named marissa
is actually able to evade her pursuers
at first but then she ends up going to
this room in a boarding house where i
presume that she's been staying and
she's looking for this guy like she goes
up to the apartment she's like hey
whatever the hell i can't remember what
his name was but she's looking for him
and while she's in there she gets jumped
by one of the sinister dudes from the
from before and actually has her throat
slashed and what's probably the movie's
most violent scene and you get to see
like the aftermath too like when the
cops come so when jeremy finds out about
the murder he kind of becomes intrigued
in this i don't think i mean the movie
doesn't make this entirely clear unless
i wasn't really paying attention but i
didn't think that he had any
relationship with this woman prior like
i don't think he was
like watching her or like he knew who
she was or that she was in danger i
think he just happened to be at this
place and started hitting on her and
then it just turned out that she was
involved in this i don't know though
because he wasn't undercover detective
so it could be that he was like watching
her or something like that i'm not
really clear on that but you know if you
know tell me because i don't know
um so yeah so he becomes intrigued after
he finds out that oh this girl he was
hitting on like got murdered now it's
suspected at first that marissa was
probably a prostitute like a sex worker
but there are some kind of rumblings
rumors and stuff like that that there's
maybe a bigger crime syndicate behind
her death
one that maybe allegedly uh pimps out
underage girls like to the highest
bidder also might be engaging in some
straight up kidnapping now to this end
there's actually kind of like a minor
subplot about the young son of a
prominent businessman in milan who gets
abducted for ransom and jeremy suspects
that this case and mur and the murder of
marissa might be like connected to the
same like big crime syndicate now as i
first mentioned
the viewer isn't actually informed that
jeremy is a cop i kind of suspected that
he might be like watching his
shenanigans like at the first in the
first part of the movie
but because his methods were so
unorthodox i thought it was also just
possible that he could be like from a
rival crime syndicate and was like
trying to figure out like what the other
dudes were up to i wasn't really sure on
that i suspected he might be a cop
because like i said i didn't read the
synopsis beforehand i read it after and
that's why i'm not like worried about
spoiling it because like i said i'm
pretty sure the synopsis says that he's
a cop before you know he's a cop he
actually ends up joining forces with
this young very young like almost
teenager 20s like petty thief a guy who
just goes around a scooter and like
snatches people's purses and [ __ ] and
breaks into people's cars and takes
their stuff his name is johnny and the
pair of them do things like hey let's
get let's both get on your scooter and
then we'll ride down the street where
all the hookers are hanging out and then
we'll snatch all their purses and at
first i was just kind of like why you
[ __ ] doing that seems like really
dickish um like taking all their body
but
it turns out that uh jeremy is actually
looking for information about this human
trafficking ring and is hoping that
maybe one of these uh one of the sex
workers like have some information in
their purse like a phone number or
something like that that he can follow
up on so that's why he's doing that he
also ends up going to this
uh
it ends up being like a front company uh
it's supposed to be like a place where
you go to like hire out domestic help
like i need a housekeeper or something
like that and it's supposed to be like a
clearinghouse for that
but
jeremy suspects this might be maybe
where the human trafficking ring is run
from so he goes in there and tries to
use like all this coded language and
stuff yeah i need a babysitter wink wit
you know what i mean that kind of stuff
jeremy even ends up engaging the
services of prostitute i think her name
is carmela in order to kind of get some
scuttlebutt about this whole thing that
he suspects is going on and then figures
well since i already paid for her time
might as well use her for intended
purpose which i was kind of like okay
i guess that's how they the cops do it
in italy i don't know uh carmella
actually ends up getting murdered
further down the line so you know uh he
actually does a similar thing
with a supposedly underage girl i think
she's supposed to be underage he asks
her how old she is but she won't say she
says old enough but i'm assuming that
she's supposed to be a minor even though
she doesn't really look like one
thankfully because that would be super
creepy uh her name is floriana now she's
actually played by um barbara men
magnolfi manuel fee uh who was in
suspiria among other things you probably
recognize her from that that's where i
recognize her so he kind of like he sets
up an appointment with her like oh i
have this client that's this really rich
oil baron that likes some young if you
know what i mean and he sets up this
appointment with her but like the guy
doesn't exist he just like wants to
figure out like what she's what her deal
is and then like after she comes in he
pays her like he doesn't have sex with
her but um he pays her and then he has
gianni like follow her to like see where
she's going because he hopes that that
will lead back to like maybe the heart
of the operation uh he also gets
floriana killed too so there's that um
you know not not a good padding average
for the guy so uh so after watching
jeremy's attics like for the first half
of the film it's finally revealed that
jeremy is indeed a detective but he's
been working undercover in an unofficial
like an official slash unofficial
capacity like on behalf of his superiors
i guess the thing about it is that well
we've been working on these kidnapping
cases
but we can't officially come out and say
that we're working on it because then
you know we'll get in trouble because
like the kidnappers are usually for
ransom and they're just kind of like hey
no cops so it's like so we want to get
involved we don't want anyone to know
we're involved because we might get
people killed so we have this guy going
around like doing some [ __ ] so jeremy is
apparently able to use whatever means he
deems necessary in order to get to the
bottom of all of these recent
kidnappings and then all the subsequent
murders that might be related
but
when he ends up discovering that this
trafficking ring might actually go much
higher up than anyone thought he ends up
running into conflict with the police
department that he's working for who
either don't really want to believe that
some of the cities cities like
wealthiest and most respected men might
be involved imagine that um or are just
afraid that if they look too hard into
the case they're kind of gonna be
putting targets on their own backs so he
gets it's it's very much like i said
like a rogue cop uh you know playing by
his own rules kind of thing where he's
always getting yelled at like by his
superiors like why'd you do this you got
this person killed and you mess this up
and blah blah so he's always getting
shouted at and like afraid like he's
gonna get fired and [ __ ] so all in all
um this was a pretty decent watch but i
i will say that i can see why it isn't
as maybe beloved as some of sergio
martino's other giallo movies i did like
the mystery aspect of this and the
character of jeremy even though he's
very very smug and he's kind of like an
arrogant douchebag he's still like
weirdly endearing which i guess is kind
of like a testament to that actor that
he's just going around like well
actuallying everybody but like you still
don't want to punch him so you know so
props there uh the score was actually
like kind of fun very funky very very
reminiscent of goblin's work on dario
argento's deep red uh for a second i was
like this has got to be claudius
cinnamon eddie too with this music but
it's not uh but obviously you can tell
that whoever did do the music they were
just kind of like i'm gonna like rip off
clients
you know what i mean so but it's fun uh
the dialogue is also pretty witty uh and
actually like made me laugh out loud a
few times although i will say that i
could have done without all the
slapstick humor because like i said
there's a few
things in there like there's car chases
and stuff like that which is fine you
know action sequences but some of the
car chases like had this goofy like
slapstick humor like the one of the
another one of the running gags other
than the broken lens on the glasses is
that jeremy has this like really really
shitty car like the door keeps falling
off and all this other kind of [ __ ] so
during this one car chase like the cops
are chasing them and he has all this
money from like a ransom it's like a
whole thing and him and johnny are in
the car and they're trying to like get
this car off their tail so he's pulling
the doors off and like throwing the
doors like throwing the door is it like
the car behind them and then there's
another thing too where they hit this
guy
and you can tell that this was this
guy's like main talent and so they made
him do it a couple times in the movie
but like he gets hit by the car and like
he spins and then like falls and then
like he spins like up on his head like
almost like a breakdancer except he's
like an older dude so i was like well
that's impressive and all but so they
did it a couple times so like i said
it's very very slap sticky and uh i
thought that was kind of strange because
i mean for a film whose main plot line
involves
trap human trafficking and essentially
like pedophilia you know
trafficking of teenage girls uh the
decision to add kind of like slap sticky
gags was very peculiar you know what i
mean so totally it's a little bit odd uh
the movie i will admit though does go a
little bit darker and more in like i
said more like a dirty hairy kind of
direction in the second half although
there is still
humor in it like like i said there's a
lot of running gags too like there's
another one about one of the police
superiors like betting on
soccer games and like he's always trying
to get like he doesn't really give a
[ __ ] about like solving murders he's
just oh that's all he talks about is
like trying to get other people to like
set up like betting pools with them like
soccer games so that's like another
running gag too it's i don't know it's
very weird and i will say too that
despite the very sleazy subject matter
uh of this movie uh it's not really the
movie doesn't come across as very sleazy
at all there is some nudity um but it's
pretty minimal like toward the beginning
and the violence is i mean barely
registers uh there is a fairly high body
count i think like maybe 11 people if
you go to like there's a great website
called i think it's called the giallo
files and he has like um
like a checklist of like all his stuff
and he'll like put the body count but i
think he said 11 people died in this but
to be honest only a couple of them get
knifed like i said the first woman like
the little orphanage woman marissa like
she gets the most gruesome death where
she actually gets her throat slash and
her face kind of like cut up but other
than that like most of the deaths are
like
thugs like goons like and it's gunfights
and stuff so it's not really like that
giallo esque but a few people like one
the big fat lady that uh is runs the
boarding house that maurice like she
gets killed later and that's like pretty
gruesome but other than that it's mostly
just like gunfights and like cop kind of
stuff so
not real super violent even though a lot
of people do die
so this movie a bit of an odd duck uh
that's for sure i would recommend it to
if you've seen all of sergio martino's
other 70s stuff just you know if you're
a completist about that because like i
said all of his other glo movies other
than this one are kind of like a lot
better regarded or like talked about
more this one doesn't get talked about
that much i hadn't seen this one but i
noticed i think arrow just put out like
a nice restored version of it not too
long ago and shutter just added it like
a week or two ago so i said oh okay well
i'll watch that one because i haven't
seen it and i think that was one of the
very few 70s sergio martino movies that
i hadn't seen but it is a little bit
different than like some of the other
ones like i said it's much more of a
police procedural and like rogue cop
type of thing rebel cop type movie so if
you like that kind of stuff then you'll
probably get it it's like don't expect
it to be creepy or gruesome or all that
horror you know it's not really all that
violent but if you're in the right mood
for it and you don't mind like a couple
of
silly comedic touches in your human
trafficking storyline
then uh you know give it a spin uh and
if you've seen it like i said the
shutter just added it not too long ago
they added like a handful of uh more
giallo movies not too long ago so if
you've watched it let me know what you
thought about it what'd you think of the
comedy did you like that like i said it
was almost it's not as funny as
something like lethal weapon or beverly
hills cop but i feel like maybe even
though this was before that obviously it
feels like that's kind of what they were
going for
um that kind of vibe but i'm not sure it
entirely works it was a little bit
uneven
especially considering the seriousness
of the subject matter but you know your
mileage may vary so let me know what you
think about it in the comments and that
will do it for this flickers of fear the
last installment of gl july so i will
see you guys on the next one bye